I think this adventure sometimes people
examine who they are what they're going
through
here they people are scared to death
that's all I've been doing is working
out you pop it pop it good yeah
[Music]
what's up buddy how are you getting Dana
what's that buddy what's up my man are
you doing man I'm awesome how are you
pretty cool this is really exciting
where are you I'm a Newport Beach but
Dana Point good for your men that's the
place to be big time where you in Vegas
right now yeah I'm in Vegas
tell me now what's going on how do you
feel being at home with the kids and the
wife what'd you say huh it's actually
been great man I've spent some awesome
time with my kids but you know my boys
are ready to head to college so as much
time as I can get with them I'm getting
I can dig it we haven't bought over
miles from Newport Beach to Dana Point
right back like a 20-minute 20 25 minute
drive yeah we're doing [ __ ] I haven't
done with them since they were little
what's this date of this morning world
madness [ __ ] crazy man it's it's uh
you know everybody's running and hiding
and and you know I'm one of those guys
that would rather get out there and find
solutions how do we figure this out how
do we how do we beat this thing listen
if you're if you're a if you're somebody
that's a high risk you should probably
stay away and stay quarantine for a
while but what happens when flu season
comes again next year what's gonna
happen then right hey I don't know it
really perplex you know I never been in
a situation like this before right now
you know besides most because they see
here days people are scared to death I
agree
I think that the media has made this
thing scary you know people are [ __ ]
buying toilet paper and [ __ ] like buying
all the toilet paper there is and I mean
if you just look at a lot of the things
that are going on it's it's wacky and
totally driven by fear well lastly imma
be thinking about in a situation like
this about viruses wiping my butt right
exactly exactly it's very weird I don't
know this is really interesting I think
this is an interesting type of people
examine who they are what they're going
through
yeah it's listen there's two sides to
the story I mean I could do this all the
time if this is what we're gonna do
I got a great house here we have we have
I'm having a blast with my family you
know like I said we're doing stuff we
haven't done since they were little my
boys are gonna leave and once you know
that how that works once your kids take
off the college man that if they ever
come back you know they'll meet a girl
though today God but if you got a wife
they got a girlfriend and they're
married before you know it
so I'll enjoy this for as long as I can
but the reality is we have to get back
to real life and start working again and
start getting things going let's figure
out solution way my son and my daughter
today they were a school they were on a
phone like a computer like this with
their teachers so they have to do they
can't go back to their class that took
their teacher or a computer right right
yeah kids are all homeschooling on the
computer can't hang out with the friends
my son my oldest one is supposed to
graduate high school this year he
probably won't even have a graduate but
you know have a normal graduation
ceremony no senior prom none of those
things that you're supposed to have as a
senior conceivable I'm sure the use of
me I'm just very curious to see how this
damn place yeah it's uh it's nuts but
I'm gonna try to pull
Tony versus Habib on April 18th and you
know try to get some normalcy back in
this in this country then the world
would need this yesterday you can make
man this is something that we need we
need something to entertain my intellect
right now this is crazy I agree with
your brother so what do you thinking
what you think these guys would be in
any place in the planet so every day
that I work on this thing I get another
another curveball water babe I get
another curveball thrown at me when I
wake up so every time we plan something
it falls apart gotta redo it redo it so
I have four or five locations right now
and we're just we're getting this deal
done we get in who we can't what we can
do and we're gonna build the cart around
it man something has to be going
absolutely bonkers is no way the human
intellect could survive this is nothing
that I don't know he's never put Indian
I just hadn't happened in my lifetime
and it'll never again yeah we're just
sophisticated for this stuff I think
that in a year or two we're gonna look
back on this thing and go holy [ __ ] we
shut down the whole world for this thing
yeah and 125 trillion dollars yeah
exactly 25 trillion just them we don't
even know we're sick or not yet somebody
said we have a virus
we don't know easy virus or now know 25
trillion dollars right it's [ __ ]
madness it's nuts
I don't know - do you have this and
celebrate some kind of way yeah when
it's over no no I'm just like I said up
I'm looking at the positive side and
just spending time with my family
hanging out at my house and doing things
that I normally don't get to do and I've
been working out like crazy I'm gonna
come out of this thing get on when I
went in that's all I've been doing is
working out he's pumping and pumping
good for carpet you don't have to suffer
to muscle and joint discomfort for the
rest of my life
I am a copper Mike
so whatever I love things how's it out
it wasn't it look like out there out in
Vegas yeah very weird all the casinos
are shut down you know no cars on the
road you know one of the things another
positive you could take out of this this
thing has been very good for the planet
they saw dolphins in Venice you know a
satellite shots of China they can see
the sky now and see the clouds and I
heard that lorenzo told me yesterday
that king yet is shutting down they're
shutting down india so you can imagine
the impact that this is going to have on
the planet over the next thirty days I
mean is looking forward to this seeing
outcomes
they'll be amazed that we're dealing
with a part of history here yeah it's
it's pretty it's pretty weird and kind
of cool it's named pack all the kids are
dead though right what's that
or you kid named at the house is good
everybody's good man we're good over
here I'm choking to death right now but
come on g-man chill talking like that
yeah exactly I'm over here talking [ __ ]
about the corona virus while I listen I
think that the president's done a good
job the CDC has done a good job and I
think our governor of Nevada Sissel Act
has done a good job you know yeah
something like this hasn't happened in
our lifetime so how do you how do you
react and how do you deal with something
like that this that pops up out of the
blue it's it's you know it's a very
tough thing to deal with it and to pull
the plug on the state of Nevada and shut
down the casinos I mean that's where all
the money comes from in this state so
very ballsy move you know every um
listen I've been a good boy I've been
doing what I've been told to do I've
been locked in my house since nano
dagnab done what I'm told to do it that
was really a me to do but I've done it
exactly so you know happy everybody's
complying and we'll see how this thing
plays out
so what do you think about Tom Brady
leaving us I'm not happy about it
I'm back you know I'll be a Patriots fan
for the rest of my life and if he
couldn't go to the Patriots I wanted him
to come here to Las Vegas he would have
been great for this town great to the
team and I can't believe it didn't work
out hey man listen something will make
something good work out of the Tom's
awesome dad we got this he really is
I'm always gonna be a Tom Brady fan no
doubt about that
I just wanna see how you over there
Florida's Florida he's gone today yeah
so every Sunday now I will be watching
the Patriots and I'll be watching the
foot you know him play in Florida he's
like I know he's like that won't kind me
Yeah right
he got it made three of the cool guy
very cool all right men videos one let
out anything else have to say brother
Tom good my brother I really appreciate
you coming on the show with me this
stuff that we doing there this time of
war anything for you Mike you know that
thank you I really appreciate it I'll be
talking to you shortly my friend all
right brother be well god bless